okay
today's speaker is professor jan
esteban from epfl he
joined epfl as
chair of computational mathematics and
simulation science in 2013
and since 2017 as dean of the school of
basic sciences
his research interests focus on the
development
analysis and application of high order
accurate methods for the solution of
complex
time dependent problems often requiring
hyper computing a particular focus of
his research has been on the development
of
computational methods for problems of
linear and non-linear wave problems
and the development of reduced basis
methods
recently we've done emphasis on
combining
traditional methods with machine
learning and neural networks with broad
applications
including structural health monitoring
he has received several awards for both
his research and his teaching and has
published
four monographs and more than 160
research papers he is on the editorial
board
of eight journals and serves as editor
in chief of science scientific computing
no further
due here is
our speaker professor hastavan he is
going to talk about
non-intrusive reduced auto model using
physics-informed neural neural networks
today okay
please enjoy thank you thank you thank
you thank you for the
for the kind invitation and the
opportunity
um as i mentioned this is a an after
dinner speech at least in this in this
part of the world but i know it's not
for you so i will
i will not make it more sort of relaxed
after dinner speech but uh
but a regular scientific presentation um
so i'll talk about uh using reduced
order models and some of you may know
them and some of you perhaps
have only heard about them um
focusing on nonlinear problems in
particular
um and and trying to
to discuss how one can use
neural network of various types
uh to solve some of the bottlenecks that
are associated with developing reduced
order models for time-dependent problems
non-linear problems in particular so
that's sort of the
this philosophy that i've taken in the
last few years
that when trying to do to look at neural
nets or machine learning technology
it's not to replace what many of us have
spent many years learning and
and 75 years of numerical analysis but
rather
to try and understand whether we can use
this technology
to to solve some of the bottlenecks that
we are traditionally
facing when we when we try to solve more
complex problems
so so what is the reduced order model
i'm sure that many of you familiar with
it
it is basically an attempt to create a
map
between a set of parameters mu
only conditions initial conditions
material parameters
geometries what have you
then there's a pde or system of pdes in
there that describes
the relationship between the parameters
and an output of interest
solution and of course you can solve
when you're sharing your standard
methods and and
you being at launch livermore knows uh
better than anyone
that some of these problems are
extremely time consuming to solve and
and the idea of having to solve them ten
thousand times
is sort of completely out of the
question so the question is can you come
up with a with a way of creating this
map
so that when you if you are willing to
to
simplify your your view or
focus your view on a particular class of
problems that you can accelerate
the solver so basically you're you're
you're trading generality
for speed as we so often do uh
so just to give you an example of what
the basic idea is let's say you have
poisson's problem here with the
right hand side f that depends on some
parameters mu it can also be the
boundary conditions
and the point is you wish to solve this
many many times
of course you can use your favorite
method find element finite difference
perhaps
perhaps a spectral method whatever you
prefer
but if the problem is a complicated
problem you need many degrees of freedom
curly end and therefore even with the
modern technology
if a is big enough it becomes expensive
and so the question is if this is the
problem you're interested can you do
better than that
and the idea of a reduced order model is
that you are saying well
let me assume that i can represent my
solution
as it changes over parameter space
as a linear combination of some
vectors which is the matrix v
which is tall and skinny so it has curly
n
number of rows but roman n
number of columns and therefore the size
of the vector a
is roman n and we simply assume that
roman n
is much much smaller than uh
the number of degrees of freedom you
have in the in the big problem
another way of looking at it is is on
the right hand side the little figure
is you're basically saying that as
you're changing the solution
over the over the uh parameter space you
have a solution manifold
and you're making an assumption that you
can represent this manifold here in 2d
with uh with a linear space okay
of course this may not be the case and
then you have other problems
but let's assume that you can and in
many cases you can but if that's the
case you simply do a projection
you represent the solution in this new
basis you project the residual
in a colloquial projection and you get a
little system of equations now
which is uh in this particular case
the main characteristic is that
that you have a problem it's a dense
problem but it's only roman n by roman
n so if you think of the number of
degrees of freedom in this
big problem being 10 000 but you only
need 10 vectors to span the linear space
you now have a 10 by 10 dense problem
you have to solve every time you change
the parameter mu
this is the basic idea reduce basis
methods
as you as you can see them in in many in
many different places
why would you want to do that well any
problem where you need to solve the
parameterized pde
optimization control problems databases
uncertainty quantification
it's also been used for as subscale
models in multi-scale modeling
and and many other situations in
particular if you want to solve
uh something on a deployed platform uh
your graphics for instance then um
there's clearly benefits in in being
able to do that
because you have only a limited amount
of computational resources
so that's the basic idea of a reduced
order model uh
it's very successful it works very very
well for for
linear problems if you're interested in
this and i put it up there because the
book is free
so you can download this book it goes
through
all the basic theory for the
basically mostly for the linear problem
and there's a nice
error theory and there's a lot of things
you can do with these methods that work
very well
you can also do it for some non-linear
problems navier stokes in particular has
been done
uh quite a bit but once you get into non
to sort of more general nonlinear
problems
you face the issue that uh it is more
complic
it is more complicated to to achieve the
acceleration that you hope for
and i'll show you a second why this is
and the second one which is which is
obvious already in the in the previous
example is that when you do this this
projection
of the operator a you have to actually
know the operator you have to have
access to the operator which means you
have to access
the code um and therefore
creating the reduced model becomes
intrusive
and and this for certain types of codes
uh either because the legacy here
because they're classified or because
their commercial codes
this is simply not possible so the
question is can we build methods
that have many of the same
characteristics but are non-intrusive
and and and what is the problem here
with the non-linearity where again
here's the generic problem now it's the
linear problem again
l dependent l operator depends on on
u you express the solution u as a linear
combination
of the vectors v put it in you do the
glucagon projection
and you get a small system that you can
solve and
and the key point is you have a method
which is independent of the number of
degrees of freedom
in uh in the original problem and
therefore you have
acceleration now if the problem is
non-linear it's of course
much less obvious how to do it because
when you form the projected operator
the projected operator depends on you
and therefore in order to evaluate the
operator l
you're going to have to recover u and
therefore you now get a scheme
which depends on the number of degrees
of freedom
in the vector u and that's exactly what
you wish to try and avoid
because now the cost of
forming and solving the reduced order
model becomes comparable to that or
solving the original problem
and and you sort of lost the benefits of
of the
of the reduced order model at least many
in many cases so the question is can we
can we
can we try and and see if there's a way
around that
now i'll i'll go through a number of
examples
uh individuals here below have been
involved at various
uh stages of the process
[Music]
where we sort of first do a
non-intrusive method
which is entirely data-driven and i'll
explain to you
how we do that then in the next level we
will include the equation
into the training and see that there can
be some benefits to that
and then for the time dependent problem
which is the last piece
the question is if i'm going to build a
reduced model and i'm going to run it
in time then what do i know
if i go beyond the time that i have
trained the model
so then you get into prediction and
and of course if if a reduced order
model for a time dependent problem
doesn't have any predictive value
then um it's it's usefulness is
less obvious so we'll discuss this a
little bit
so uh first one so what does it mean by
non-intrusive
well as i hinted to the idea is that you
want to have them
have the ability to build to build
reduced order models
where all you have is a piece of code
that
can provide you input output i give it a
parameter
i get back the solution i don't need to
actually look inside the code
and as soon as you go down that's that
step
you realize that you cannot form the the
reduced
order problem by projection because you
don't have access to the operators
and therefore the key problem becomes
how to go
from finding from choosing a parameter
to actually getting the expansion
coefficients if you will
that you then use to multiply onto the
weights and get the
produce to get the solution okay so
that's exactly
the point then of course what can you
say about accuracy so
um so how would one do that the simplest
way
is that you do some sort of function
approximation
you say here on the left the solution u
is a linear combination of the vectors v
the alpha depends on the parameters mu
i don't know how they uh vary
if you do intrusive you have an equation
for how to find the alphas
of course another way is to do you could
attempt to do interpolation
simply finding uh alpha for a particular
choice of the parameters
and then use radial basis functions so
some sort of unstructured
interpolation and and and do that and
of course people have tried that
especially with radial basis functions
and it has all the challenges that
radius basis functions
has especially when you go up in high
dimensions uh
it gets quite poorly conditioned uh and
it's expensive it leads to large dense
matrices that you have to solve
so that's not necessarily the the best
way
and and so what we are proposing here in
this one as well so let's use a dual net
for this exercise so neural nets are
known to be
good for dealing with uh with the
high dimensional input output basically
creating
input output maps
with the high dimensional uh inputs and
outputs
so in this case the input would be the
parameter values
it can be two or three can also be 100
if you're not depending on the problem
and then on the right outside these will
be the weights
what i call the alphas and and then
you will you will we will try to learn
um
and you will net a simple feed forward
neural net that connects directly the
parameters to the expansion coefficients
okay now and we would use we'll use
super supervised learning for that
okay so the ideas is quite simple if you
don't know what renewal that is which
i'm sure is it's not the case here
well it's it's basically uh layers of
what is called neurons here which are
which are
non-linear functions of fine
combinations of the solutions
in the previous layer if there's more
than one hidden layer it's a deep neural
net
so there's a number of choices you have
to make
in how you go from the inputs to the
outputs those are the weights then
there's a bias
that you have to to compute and then
there's an activation function it's the
activation function that makes the
neural net non-linear and
so so when you talk about training what
does it mean well it means i have some
input data and have some output data
and i have to try and find out what are
the weights and what are the biases
so that this function uh
approximates the input output map as
well as i can
okay and this is a non-linear uh
non-convex optimization pole
that that needs to be solved so
so the first thing you have to ask
yourself is okay so neural nets are used
to all kinds of things
why would you think that it would work
in this context
well the thing is as we just discussed
the neural net is really just a highly
non-linear approximation
and and
and the function we're trying to
approximate is a function that
maps the parameter space to the
expansion coefficients
now if that's a very very complicated
function it means that as i change the
parameters a little bit the expansion
coefficients would change a lot
that would be a very sensitive and
unpleasant problem and it's it's very
unlikely
that there would be a good reduced basis
for something like that
so it's entirely reasonable to assume
that if there is a good reduced order
model
that then this map is actually a
relatively smooth map and a simple map
and therefore we should in fact be able
to create newer nets that are quite
small
that would allow you to do that
and the forward problem we can solve as
many as
as much as we need we can just so we can
generate the data from the forward
solver
we don't need to know the code we just
need to say i give you the parameters
you give me the solution i project the
solution onto the linear space
i have the expansion coefficients and i
can generate as much
data as i think i need now of course
every data set is a computation for the
full solver
so we want to reduce that and i'll get
to that a little bit later
but in principle you can generate the
the
the data that you need and then once you
have
uh trained you can go so let's see if it
works so this is the idea
we built the the reduced order model
exactly as we will do
with the standard way by taking
snapshots or using a greedy approach
doing svd
this gives you the vector the vector
space v
and then sample parameter space to
generate another set of snapshots this
is the training data
use this for training the neural net and
then in the online phase
there's no projected problem you simply
evaluate the neural net
to evaluate the non-linear problem
so here's a couple of things so this is
a relatively simple problem it's 1d but
it has some characteristics that i want
to share with you because you will see
it later on
so it's a it's a 1d problem or some
problem but it's a non-linear problem
as you can see there are two parameters
in the problem
on the boundary conditions and uh
on the right are some are some examples
of solutions that's not so important
on the left is sort of what we what we
need to look at here so i'll spend a
minute of that because we'll see the
behavior
so the horizontal lines
is the error that we make by taking
a particular solution and projecting it
on
to um as to the linear space
of size either 8 or 15 in other words
this is the best accuracy we can get
this is the best accuracy you can get
with the linear space of size 8 or 15.
cannot do better than that
now let's say the light blue
so that's the that's the results that i
get
with uh 50 training points
and the horizontal axis signifies that i
have two layers in the neural net
and then it is the number of neurons
these are very small neural nets
okay and this is on purpose because i
want to be fast
um so there's small neural nets 10 20 30
neural nets
neurons two layers and what you see is
that
uh in fact as you increase the number of
of
of neurons with only 30 but only 50
trading points in fact the error goes up
now if you increase the number of
trading points and do the same exercise
you see that the arrow sort of stays
flat and then it goes up
and as you increase as you as you add
more and more
training you see that the solution
eventually comes down
even which you have uh a large neural
net
so this as i'm sure many of you have
have seen this is what is called over
parameterization and it's uh
it's in this particular case what you're
seeing is uh is overfitting
so when you don't have enough data for
the richness of the
of the of the new net uh you're
overfitting you're basically
interpolating but it's a
it's a random grid if you will so you
get
very severe rumor type phenomena
behavior
and then this is why the error goes up
when you look at over a
test set in this case now why is this
useful
well because we can use this to actually
design the the
the net the architecture of the net so
if you look at the arrow
you can see that what we're interested
in is the difference between the
solution the exact solution
and the predictive solution using the
dual net
and we can split it into three with the
with the triangle inequality so it's the
first piece
so the first piece is the difference
between the exact solution
and the solution i will be computing if
i'm using
my big expensive solver so this is just
a this is an approximation final element
approximation theory
there's a lot of that the next one is
the error that i make by taking the
computed solution
and projecting it onto the space v okay
this is an error component and i have a
third component which is the arrow
between
the projected solution and the one
predicting being predicted by the by the
neural net
okay so the first two pieces are well
quite well understood how you can
represent those understand those the
third one is basically comes down to
error analysis
of the dual net this is still uh
not something that is terribly well
understood especially when then when
that is deep
so we have an estimator like that
however we're going to use overfitting
now to try and control that error so we
do it in the following way
so it's exactly the same problem as
before i have 100 training points
now i increase the size of the network
uh
from 10 to 15 neurons the year goes down
that's good
stagnates and eventually here with 25
nodes
you see the sign of overfitting now you
can decide whether you think that
6 times 10 to the minus 4 is good enough
for what you're looking at
if it is then you're done then you
should be using a neural net with the
two layers and 20 neurons if not
the only way of improving matters is by
increasing the number of training points
so we go to 200 training points you see
exactly the same
trend it goes down now we get down to
the black line
which is the best we can hope for uh in
this particular test and eventually
also here it goes up so
so with this you can you can at least in
in in this approach
you can basically define or help on
overfitting helps you understand what is
the what is the appropriate size
of the network now of course if you have
100 layers and a billion neurons
i appreciate that this is a more
difficult exercise but i'm
deliberately not looking at that limit
i'm looking in the limit of very small
networks because i need to be fast
to do things on the fly so here's a more
complicated or slightly more complicated
problem that is stokes 2d
uh but with a non-fine mapping of the of
the
of the domain doing this with a standard
found
that it's quite complicated and it's not
at all obvious how
to do um how to get this accelerated
um now if you look at the solution so
here sort of eyeball
solutions you can see that they look
fine the top ones are the final elements
the bottom ones
are they are the reduced order model
with the dual net
if you look at the arrows exactly the
same way as we talked about them
with having enough
having enough of training data
depending on the size you can certainly
reach the accuracy that you
that you want and if you look at the
actual arrows
rather than than than the generalization
error which
is the the top one so here what we do is
you
you compute the the actual arrow of the
solution
as you increase the basis so it's now
the basis
now the red one is the projection of the
x of the
of the high fidelity solution so this is
the let's say this is the best you can
get
um the blue the blue balls
the blue round balls this is the this is
the very expensive
one where you go through the full
galerkin projection so fully intrusive
and you see that the air goes down
at least in the velocity which is the
left the pressure is on the right
but the nature of the non-linear system
that you have to solve is not very
pleasant
it's extremely poorly conditioned and
therefore you see
a fairly large error in this particular
case
whereas the the whereas the neural net
works very well it doesn't get quite as
good as the as the projection of the
high fidelity but it gets very close and
and you basically see almost exponential
convergence
in the individual spaces which is what
you would
what you would expect and of course the
issue here is the cost which is the
important one
uh if you do it fully intrusive
with um can
uh compare to doing it with the with the
training the neural net and using that
in order to predict the errors
or to the solution there's an
acceleration here of a factor of a
thousand at least
and and the training that goes into
training the network because it's a
relatively small network
is marginal if indeed you need to solve
the problem
many many times
so so the message here is that there's
certainly something to be done by using
the neutral net
to create directly the map between the
parameters and the expansion
coefficients
in this case it was a purely data driven
approach and you can
the beauty of it is you can do it for
any problem non-linear
and all you need is a black box solver
fully non-intrusive
now the problem with the approach i've
just described
is that it's difficult to get good
accuracy so if you need
you know 10 to the if you need if 10
error is good or
maybe if you work hard you can get down
to one percent error
then then what i just described is
probably
if you need more than that it becomes
very difficult to do it you have to be
very careful when you train and when you
parameterize the network
and the second thing is and we have
already seen that is that you need quite
a bit of training data
you know 200 300 400
solutions for basically 2d navier stokes
that's a that's a lot uh so the question
is can we do something about that
and of course the issue here is that
there's something that we haven't used
and i'm focusing on steady state but you
can also do it for time dependent
there's something here that we haven't
used which is we haven't used the
equation we have only used data
um and we do have an equation of course
uh but in the first approach we just
used it to to generate the data so this
gets very much into the spirit
of of what my former colleague george
kanedakis has been working on on on what
he what he calls physics-informed neural
nets
where where you use the equation in the
in the um in the training of the network
and so what i just described and now
there are basically three different
models here so what i just described is
one
where you you define the loss function
as a loss function on the error that you
make
in predicting the expansion coefficients
over parameter space
okay so o here is the newer net
alpha is your training data and you try
to train
o so that you minimize this loss
it's a purely data-driven approach um
now of course the other way of trying to
do things is is what one could call what
is called
physics and fault neural nets where
you don't use the data but you only use
the residuals so you train
to minimize uh the
the prediction of the neural net such
that
uh the residual is minimized
so you use the equation but you actually
never use the solution
and of course it's natural to then think
about well maybe you should
do some sort of linear combination of
the two where you both have a data
driven part
and and a uh physics informed part um
and and so this is the approach that we
take
and then and we'll see quickly that in
fact that seems to have some benefits
uh addressing the two problems that we
talked about so here's the
lid driven cavity again parameters
arrayless numbers as well as the angle
and this so this one is a little
complicated so let me spend a minute on
this one
so um so again the black line
are the projection of the exact solution
as you increase the size of the bases
okay so think of the black lines as this
is the best you can get
the the yellow lines on top
are three different this number of uh
of amount of training
data they vary but but they but the
point is this you can see that that
here we have errors which are 10 to the
minus 2 maybe a little bit
worse than that and this is for the
approach
that i just described so this is the
purely data-driven approach
and here we see that it's difficult to
get better than 10 to the minus two
accuracy even if you pour in a lot of
training data
the red lines here in the middle of the
of the
of the graph this is the accuracy
of the full deloikan approach so the
fully
intrusive calorical approach so this
of course behaves quite reasonably
but is is very very expensive
okay the dashed lines
the dashed line is the residual
is the residual base so this is the pin
it's the residual based
only and then the green line
is the combination of the data and the
residual
now why would that work better well we
all know that the residual is not the
arrow and if
all the information that you give is
only
the residual you can drift quite far
away from the solution
so adding some solution some actual
solutions
a few data points to the um
to the training actually can gain in
this case
an order of magnitude and accuracy with
a relatively
minimal uh effort because those are the
only snapshots
that you need these are the full
solutions everything else is just
residual
here are some visuals and you again you
can see that the neural nets are small
five layers 30 neurons
um so they are not big nets
um natural convection sort of a similar
idea but now we have three parameters in
this case
the the cavity can tilt and then there's
the rayleigh and the prandtl number
and and again you see the same picture
you can see the colors and so on the
details are not so important
the point is that the yellow ones is the
purely data driven
the blue the green dashed line is purely
residual based
and the green lines is the one where you
combine them
in a reasonable way in order to to
with the goal of reducing the need for
many solutions
uh while doing better than simply using
the residual
so and again you can you can visually
the solutions are
all fine so
so this sort of gives you a gives
provides a path for using
a combination of reduced order models
and neural nets relatively simple feed
forward neural nets
that can be trained in various ways in
particular in the cost function
in order to take advantage of that and
of course when you're training in the
cost function you're using also
to shoot the reduced order model to
evaluate the
the residual so you see the acceleration
of that also
in training the reduced order model it's
turning the renewable net sorry
now the last thing i wanted to talk
about uh
is what to do about errors so here's a
so now we're looking at time dependent
problems
uh again so here's a
pde on od let's say it's a pde that you
discretize
we have found the linear space v you do
the projection you get an equation
for the expansion coefficients they
depend on time as well as the parameters
here they're called omega and you have a
right hand side that you need to
evaluate
now if you look at the little graph
there's sort of a few things
to keep in mind here the black line
u is the exact solution okay we have no
way of finding that we don't know it
and in fact we are representing we're
trying to look for the solution
uh it's sort of a linear space
uh spanned by v
now the the
the blue solution is the
is the projection of the exact solution
onto
that linear space
oh hi hi jen hi
hi then
hello yeah did we lose his audio yeah i
think i
we lost his audio but i don't think he
can hear us
either um i'm
not sure maybe send a chat directly to
him
um why
okay why is it happening
hey hey dan i'm sorry
um hey dan
um hello
don't know i i have no idea how to
inform him
um about it he likes stop his screen
share
he's noticed that at least oh okay
you can hear me oh okay we lost you
like yeah i know i don't know what
happened why did you lose me
uh okay we we were with you with this
slide
um here no next slide we were with you
yeah with you yeah okay very good yeah
my headset is getting tired but uh but
uh
fine so so if you look at this model
here which is a well-known model
and you say okay so why one are the
solutions you care about y2 with the
unresolved solutions
then of course you can integrate the
second equation uh
get an exact expression you can plug
that into the first equation and you get
an equation
just for the result scale or for the
part of the solution that you care about
and and and it's illustrative to sort of
look at what the components are so
there is an equation which is just for
the equations of this resolved scales
and usually when we were solving if you
were solving the first
system and you couldn't afford to solve
both for y1 and y2
you would just solve for y1 and that
would give you the solution of y1
but of course you would you would you
would you would not get the interactions
with y2
if you on the other hand look at the
equation down here you have two
additional terms there's an exact
expression
the one to the very right is the effect
of uh of
initial conditions that are in y2
okay so if you don't if you have things
that are expressed only in y2 but not in
y1
then that error will accumulate in time
let's take that error to be
zero in other words the initial
conditions are expressed only in the
in y1 then there's still a term which is
a memory term
and this term basically accounts for the
accumulation
of the impact of y1
or of y2 on y1 okay and
fine so it's not a surprise it basically
means this is the term that accumulates
the errors
this is an extract this is that this is
an exact solution an exact expression
but of course it's not a very
interesting expression because
evaluating the memory term the way it's
written
is is very very expensive so it's not
for it's for insight only
and troy and alexander turin uh 20 years
ago sort of worked through this and
generalized it
uh to general systems of of uh
differential equations uh i introduced
the projection
operator but it gives you exactly the
same
sort of structure where you have uh
let's say y hat are the result scales
um and until there are the on result
scales
and then you have an equation which
depends only on the result
scales then you have something that
depends on the initial conditions
of the components that are not expressed
in y hat and then you have the memory
term okay so again we take
big f to be zero and in this whole
exercise enter something called
called a projector so at the at the
bottom left
you have two uh operators p and q
p is the projector and q is is its
complement
now in the context of a reduced order
model you naturally have a projector
because it is it is the projector that
projects it onto the space that you have
and then there's the orthogonal
complement
so you have a very natural way of
thinking of what the projector should be
which is otherwise always a
headache but we still have the memory
term now what does the memory term do
well it accounts for the effect of all
the scales that you have not taken into
account
over time and understanding this is sort
of the key
uh and and uh fine but and i just want
to show you just to give you an insight
because it gives a little bit of
intuition what does this kernel do
well if you look at this kernel k how it
behaves
for something say like the i think this
is the this is the viscous burgers
equation
you see that that uh
it's a kernel which decays very rapidly
in time or
in in time separation it basically tells
you that
that there's a finite time memory if you
make it
if you make an arrow in the viscous
burglars after a certain amount of time
you are no longer impacted by that arrow
it has washed out
because of the viscosity
and then here we see that that if you
think of the projector as the
as the one that separates the scales
then
as the projector gets gets more and more
modes
and therefore the projection gets more
accurate
the leftover uh decays faster and faster
okay
so this is this is what it shows um
but it has this sort of rapid decay if
there's a if there's viscosity
if it's a pure weight problem then
there's no decay
and it's a much more complicated problem
um
now you can you can play around with
this you can try to estimate these terms
and so on
uh it's very problem dependent and the
terms the
the the bounds you can get in order to
estimate the memory term are often very
conservative
so we're going to look at in a slightly
different way because we have a reduced
order model
and this means that we already have two
pieces of information
we have the full solver
that we have to run in order to create
the snapshots
that allows us to build the reduced
order model and then we have the reduced
order model
and that one we can run at very low cost
which means
we can compare and we can generate
data that says if the solution behaves
like this
then the error between the high fidelity
solution
and the reduced order model is like that
and this is the correction that i need
so i can i can create a map
between a history term which is here
alpha n and sum what's backs in time
and the error that i make between the
reduced order model
and the full and the full model okay
and so this is where we use uh now
a different kind of neural net which is
an lstm long short term memory
network to train such that if i give the
network a sequence of solutions
backwards in time it tells me about the
what they
what this memory term should be and this
can then be
used to correct the solution okay so
it's a relatively simple idea once you
go through the different steps so here's
i'll show you two examples
and then we're at the end so here's a
here's a linear
so now it's a 3d problem it's a linear
problem uh it's an artery
human artery and the
forcing on the inflow is you can think
of it as a heartbeat
and fine here we go and and the the
solution
uh that we're generating we're learning
solutions
for the periods 0 to 4.
now a couple of things that we have to
understand but first of all we have to
understand how many modes do we need in
our reduced order model
you can do two standard ways of doing
that
we use 16 okay so for 16 we should have
an error of the order
10 to the minus 3 something like this
which is probably enough
and the second question that you have to
to ask yourself is well
these lstms they have a number of cells
and they're somehow related to the
length of the time history but how many
cells do you need
now it turns out that using the the
moisture on thick formulation
you can actually estimate how much
memory you need
um and and this is actually what the
what the what the black
line here is and the two different uh
paragraphs is all you need to know
all you need to observe is that you can
see that these
horizontal lines these lines which are
which are for increasing of for
different numbers of neurons
in the in the lstm you can see that
there's sort of a dip
or sort of a plateau in terms of the of
the minimum accuracy
and it aligns very well in this
particular case it looks like we need
four
cells so we can actually estimate the
number of cells
in order to to do what we what we would
like to do
and so here are some results so here
we're just looking at the
at the energy and not the point-wise
solution just the energy
in the expansion coefficients and um
[Music]
uh okay so let's look so zero to four
again this is the time that we have
trained
four to seven or four to eight is beyond
the training period
so now we're getting into phenomena that
actually uh
the reduced order model has never seen
nevertheless the solution here is
is almost periodic and you can see that
the the red line which is what we
predict and the dashed line which is
the full order solution basically
overlapped so you cannot see here
visually
a big difference but if instead look at
the arrow
you can see a big difference so the blue
line
is the arrow in the solution uh
for different parameters uh in the in
the columns
and you can see that in the on the left
which is
which is for the time periods where we
have actually trained so
we know we have used the information
you can see that by adding this memory
term you gain
four orders of magnitude sometimes six
orders of magnitude
in accuracy over time so this little
memory term actually makes a big
difference
uh even for a problem which is as simple
as this one which is
sort of quasi-periodic and and you can
see that this this goes deep into the
to the prediction where you actually
predict twice
beyond the training and still with an
accuracy of maybe 10 to the minus 3
on average compared to the solution
with no correction where basically you
have lost the solution
very quickly so that little correction
actually matters it's not snap snaps are
the solutions
it's not so important but let's look at
the act let's look at the
the at the speed because at the end of
the day that's that's what's going to
matter now this is a linear problem
so the the the light blue is the
accuracy
it's the time that it takes to solve
to do to do one time step
as you increase the number of modes
compared to the accuracy
of the overall solution and you see that
let's say you take
28 modes in
in the full pod you don't do any
correction
then uh you get an error of maybe 10
now with the with the correction you get
the same accuracy with only 16 modes
which is nice but it is more than twice
as expensive it cost
and the reason for that is that the cost
of the non-linear problem
because of the linear problem and the
pud of the linear problem
is very low so for the linear problem
this is probably not a particularly
interesting idea so let's look at the
non-linear problem instead so again
here's the two day
2d rayleigh banner problem
three layers again and so on we go
through exactly the same exercise i will
look at the solutions again
this is the energy exchange on the left
is the training now we train from 0 to
on the right is the prediction
and you can see on the left everything
looks to be fine as you would hope for
on the right the lstm
does reasonably well although of course
eventually the solutions drift apart
but very very slowly
if you instead say well what what
happens if i just don't do the
correction
now if i don't do the correction again
here there's
there are
different parameters and then there's
the prediction
there's the training and then there's
the prediction the red curve
is the solution that you get if you
don't correct
so you get a solution in the reduced
order model which is
nicely periodic as you would expect for
the rayleigh barnard convection
but the phase and the amplitude is
completely wrong
so this is the worst kind of solution
that you can do computationally because
it looks right
but it's wrong
and whereas if you do the correction um
you get the the uh the dashed line and
the blue line is the high fidelity so
you can see that that small correction
actually
throws it right back even into the
prediction uh twice as far out as
as as you want and if you look at the
solution here at the end
then okay so now you will have four
pictures so on the
upper left is the full order solution so
this is the full
this is the expensive solver the one
next to it
is the projection of the expensive
solver so again this is the best you can
hope for
if you want to compare the lower left is
the result using the pod golokin
so the expensive solver with the full
projection
and on the lower right is the one
where you do lstm
in order to correct for the for the
error or the for the memory term
so t equals 10 so you have just started
and you can see already here the purity
golurkin and the projection of the full
solution
uh are different whereas for the lstm
there
the differences are minimal 25 we're
still in the middle of the training
so so some sense the reduced model
should know what's going on but it
doesn't
70 we're now into the prediction domain
and you can see that the pure d golokin
is completely overwhelmed by the errors
that has been made
because of the truncation and here 85
the picture is the same again the
projection and the lstm
the one with the modified with the lstm
is
basically indistinguishable
to the full order so last thing is then
cost
well now you can start seeing benefits
because here
if we say we have 24 this is the red
bullet let's look at the on the left
this is the red bullet
m equals 24 mode with the correction
with the memory term correction and the
time takes
you know 0.4 times 10 to the minus 2
for for a time step of an accuracy of of
let's say 10 to the minus 3 little less
than that you get the same thing
if you do 90 modes in the pd so in the
fully intrusive
approach but it is three times as
expensive
so when the problem is non-linear you
can see the clear benefit
of using a reduced order model which is
smaller
but accounting accurately for the error
that you're making
by learning what the memory term should
be
and applying it through the lstm when
you run the code
so a few final words here um
the idea that i've been proposing here
is sort of a mix of things but the idea
is
i don't like to think of of neural nets
taking over
how we solve pdes but i do think it's
important to ask ourselves if some of
the bottlenecks that we fight with
perhaps can be overcome and and that's
what i've tried to demonstrate
the perhaps most attractive feature is
that everything is non-intrusive you can
do
these approaches for basically any
problem
you can reduce the number of training by
using the equation if you have an
equation
and with the most function you can
correct for errors that you make in time
especially if you want to go beyond the
period of time where you have
trained so you get into the prediction
domain which is obviously
of interest so with that thank you very
much for your attention i don't know
what the time is but
i'm sure i'm at the end of it and also
right so
thank you thank you thank you so much
for the quick talk uh we have uh minutes
left for the q a session so i'm sorry
it's okay it's okay but um
so if you have any questions please um
please speak up because i don't see any
questions on the chat room
so unmute yourself and then uh try to
you know speak out here yeah
please while we are waiting um
i have one question for dan um
you know if your solution representation
itself is
it's not good like with the linear
subspace
you know you know basis um
then there's no you know hope that
with that non-intrusive method you can
get
you can improve accuracy right there's
no magic here
there's no magic right yeah so if you so
so so you could do all of this
everything that i have described you can
do uh
with a really bad solver right i mean
the whole machine will work you can
build the reduced basis you can build
the model
you can learn the memory term you can do
all these sorts of things
but if the solver itself gives you
generates a bad linear space
uh well then you're converting to a bad
solution
right right do have you think
have you thought about uh to improve
that
um the solution representation
well so yeah so so they they
the last part of the talk sort of
suggests that oh but you know maybe you
could use the same idea to get rid of
you know approximation errors somehow
right but but it's
very difficult to see how to do this
because you you will you will need
a way of estimating the arrow that
you're making but this you don't know
right so you need you need a so so what
what allows you to do this approach here
is that you have
you have a solver that hopefully does a
good job
and then you play the reduced order
model that hopefully is faster
and then you you learn the difference
between the two so you can do it fast
and accurate at the same time
but if you don't have these sort of two
solvers where one is fast and one is
accurate
then you can't really play this game and
of course if if all you have is a very
large and extremely complicated code
then you know it's not easy to see how
to get that other piece of information
well this is jerome i was thinking about
that what if you did it in a little bit
of a three level
you know you can think of running your
uh your black box code
you know with different levels of mesh
refinement yeah you could probably do
something like that yes i agree you
could do something like that but you
sort of think of it as an extrapolation
type
uh approach and then you yes i agree you
could you could attempt something like
this
and then in some instances the black box
code also
has error estimates not always yes yes
yes yes so if you of course if you have
air estimates you can you can you can
play with that
and you can but but but yes you could
you could
perhaps do some of this i've never tried
but you could perhaps do some of the
same things
if you had uh you know you ran your code
at different levels of resolution
and then you learn the error that you
make and then at the end of the day
you can run your your fast code but with
the correction
right which is what you're suggesting
and and yeah that's that's what i was
thinking about yeah
yeah no i think that's worthwhile trying
i haven't i haven't tried
also because i mean i i have to say also
because i'm
you know i'm i primarily work in in wave
problems
wave dominated problems and this this
game of of uh
of uh you know running at a course grid
this doesn't work for wave problems
right
okay thank you dan uh time's up and it's
it's 11.
um so let's thank our speaker jen today
and thank you thank you very much for
your attention and for
for the opportunity and
thank you thank you okay thank you so
much for